[Musique]
vous savez, beaucoup de gens pensent que cela s'en
va en avril avec la chaleur, car la chaleur
arrive généralement, et en
avril, nous sommes en pleine forme, bien qu'ils
aient dit que cela pourrait  être pire et j'ai
dit que ça pourrait être pire - êtes-vous tous
quelque chose non je ne pense pas que ce soit
inévitable je ne pense pas que ce soit inévitable
je pense que nous faisons un très bon
travail en termes de maintien des frontières et
de changement en termes de  laisser les gens entrer en
termes de contrôle des gens à cause de tout ce que
nous avons fait, le risque pour le
peuple américain reste très faible vient de Chine
celui-ci vient de Jeff Je veux être
précis, avez-vous vu quelque chose
à ce stade qui vous donne un high
degré de confiance que Wu Han
a institué la virologie était à l'origine oui
oui et je pense que l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
devrait avoir honte d'elle-même parce qu'elle
est comme l'agence de relations publiques
pour la Chine Chine nous ne sommes pas contents de
la Chine je vais vous dire  que l'encre
n'était pas sèche sur un grand accord commercial et tout d'
un coup la peste arrive de
Chine nous n'en sommes pas contents nous avons frappé
le corps avec une énorme
lumière ultraviolette ou simplement très puissante
et je pense que vous avez dit  cela a une magie
mais nous allons le tester et puis j'ai dit
en supposant que vous apportiez la lumière à l'intérieur
du corps dans laquelle vous pouvez faire soit
à travers la peau ou d'une certaine manière
et je pense que vous avez dit que vous allez tester
ça aussi  et puis je vois que le désinfectant
frappe en une minute et y a-t-il un
moyen de faire quelque chose comme ça par
injection à l'intérieur ou presque le nettoyage
parce que vous voyez que ça pénètre dans les poumons et
ça fait un nombre énorme comme donc ce
serait intéressant de  vérifiez cela pour que
vous deviez faire appel à des médecins,
mais cela semble intéressant pour
moi Brooklyn et le z-pak, je pense que c'est une
combinaison qui a probablement l'air très
très bien et ça va être
distribué avec 10 000 unités en cours et
ça  sera distribué demain, il y a de
fortes chances que cela puisse avoir un
impact énorme, ce serait
un cadeau de Dieu si cela fonctionnait, cela
changerait la donne, mais je reçois
beaucoup de nouvelles extrêmement positives sur l'
hydroxy que j'ai pris  pendant environ
une semaine chez moi pendant environ une semaine et demie à un
moment donné tous les jours je prends une pilule
tous les jours c'est une recommandation ils le
recommandent je me sens bien
oui je pense porter un masque facial pendant que je
salue les présidents les premiers ministres
les dictateurs  rois reines je ne sais pas d'
une manière ou d'une autre je ne le vois pas par moi-même je juste je juste
peut-être que je vais changer tu ne veux pas
retourner au travail j'entends je
l'entends fort et de la bière de tout le monde
quelqu'un  a perdu quelqu'un un parent ou une
femme ou un mari ou vous connaissez des
frères sœurs peut-être perdu quelqu'un qu'il ne
pourrait jamais rattraper en disant
pourquoi vous allez avoir une excellente année l'
année prochaine économiquement et donc vous ne pouvez jamais
faire ça mais je le ferai  dire que d'un
point de vue économique, je pense que l'année prochaine
sera une très grande année cette
énorme demande
[Musique]